PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hi, I'm Priyanka.
And today, I'll be talking
to you about serverless API
development.
After a quick
introduction, I'll also
provide a demo of how
to build and manage
serverless APIs with the
Google Cloud API Gateway.
So stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Adoption of serverless computing
offers a profound paradigm
shift in developers' ability
to create highly scalable
applications and services.
This architecture
considerably improves the way
modern applications and
services are created
by allowing developers
to build without worrying
about the setup and
maintenance of the underlying
infrastructure.
And by adding an API facade to
these serverless applications,
developers can
seamlessly connect data,
integrate systems, and
build modern applications.
As organizations are
expanding their API programs,
a key question
continues to come up--
how do we make APIs
lightweight on the client side
yet highly scalable and secure
to meet the changing traffic
demands?
To accomplish this,
many organizations
have been migrating their
business-critical APIs
to serverless architecture.
Developers package
services functions
as RESTful APIs to increase
security of their services
with monitoring and
controlling access to data,
protecting these
services from bot
attacks and other
malicious traffic,
improving performance with
rate limiting and caching,
and identifying important
insights from analytics data
extracted from monitoring,
alerting, logging, and tracing.
With Google Cloud
API Gateway, you
can create, secure,
and monitor APIs
for Google Cloud
serverless back ends.
It enables you to provide
secure access to your back end
services through a
well-defined REST
API that is consistent
across all your services
regardless of the
service implementation.
It can manage APIs for
multiple back ends,
including Cloud Functions,
Cloud Run, App Engine, Compute
Engine, and Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Built on Envoy, API Gateway is
fully managed by Google Cloud
to give you high performance,
scalability, and the freedom
to focus on development.
API Gateway gives you all
the operational benefits
of serverless APIs
while reducing
the complexity of
implementation,
such as flexible
deployment and scalability,
so that you can focus on
building great applications.
Additionally, Google
Cloud API Gateway
adds layers of security
control, such as authentication
and key validation,
by configuring
security definitions that
require all incoming calls
to provide a valid API key.
It also allows you to set
quotas and specific usage
limits to protect your APIs
from abuse or excessive usage.
Let's take a quick look.
Here at Google,
we continue to see
a lot of developers
building their APIs on top
of microservices.
So in this example, we've
deployed a weather API
on Cloud Run.
It's made up of four
different services.
This is great for you
as an API provider,
because it gives you
a lot of flexibility
around how you deploy and
scheme these services.
But as an API
consumer, you don't
want to keep track
of which service
is responsible for
which piece of the API.
You just want one
interface that you
can call to access all
the capabilities provided
by this API.
So let's take a look at how
Google Cloud's API Gateway can
help you combine all
these services into one
easy-to-use API.
To get started, we will need
an OpenAPI specification
that defines each of the
resources in our API.
Next, we will add
instructions that
tell the API gateway where
to route the request for each
of those resources.
And finally, we will
want to secure our APIs.
So we will configure
a security definition
that requires all the incoming
calls to provide a valid API.
Once we have our
OpenAPI specification
and we are ready to
create our API gateway,
first we'll specify
the display name
and give our API a
unique identifier.
Next, we will define the
API's initial configuration
by uploading our OpenAPI file.
We'll then give our
configuration a display name
and configure the
service accounts
that will be used to call
our back end services.
And finally, we are ready to
deploy our API configuration
to a new gateway.
In this case, that gateway will
run in the US central region.
Once we hit Create,
after a few minutes
our gateway will be ready to
start accepting incoming API
requests.
Because we have secured our API,
we will need valid credentials.
In this case, we have elected
to use API keys as our security
mechanism.
So we can get an API key for
our API in the APIs and Service
section of the
Google Cloud console.
Once we have our key,
we can make an API call
from the command
line using Chrome.
If we tried to access our
API without providing a key,
the call would be
affected by the gateway.
Once we add our
key to the request,
the gateway then allows our
call to go through successfully.
That was just a
quick preview of how
you can use Google Cloud API
Gateway to create and secure
your APIs.
You can leverage API Gateway
for a number of important use
cases, such as abstracting back
end complexity to facilitate
development for web and
mobile applications;
connecting users to in-house and
third-party APIs and services,
especially those provided
by Google Cloud; controlling
access for partners while rate
limiting the number of calls
from each partner; and extending
data services to enable
frictionless service-oriented
access to data.
Now it's your turn
to try it out.
Get started by clicking the
link in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]